Speaker 1: Hey, things continuing to get worse
for Donald Trump's former personal attorney,
Rudy Giuliani. Rudy's law license has
now been suspended in Washington, D.C.,
the district. You might remember that recently
Rudy's law license was suspended in New York.
The District of Columbia now suspended Rudy
Giuliani from practicing law in Washington.
This was triggered automatically because
Giuliani was suspended in the state of New York.
My understanding is that Rudy is in Rudy is via
reciprocity, allowed or was allowed to practice
in D.C. And so when the state from which you are
receiving the reciprocity, suspend your license,
you are essentially automatically suspended.
Giuliani's license to practice law in New York
was suspended in a ruling that cited his false and
misleading claims as statements about the election
loss of former President Donald Trump getting
suspended in one state in this case, prompting
the automatic or near automatic suspension in
D.C.. But this is not really looking good for
Donald for for Rudy Giuliani. And you know what
I was thinking? If Rudy Giuliani, for better
or worse, in 2002, Rudy Giuliani had
extraordinarily high approval. He had been
mayor of New York at the time of 9/11. He could
have retired then and he would have remained,
I believe, much beloved. Whatever you think about
his handling of 9/11, the perception was that it
was very good and that he brought people together,
New Yorkers together, Americans together,
et cetera. He could have retired in 2002. He
could just have done consulting. He'd be rich,
he'd be powerful. He would be beloved. And
instead, he ends up known for farting during bogus
hearings, if we can even call him that, about
completely laughable voter fraud claims,
gets covid, takes him off of it, off
of the trail of doing these hearings,
then gets his law license suspended in New York.
Now it's suspended in D.C. Trump has reportedly
completely abandoned Rudy. It's not clear Rudy
has even gotten paid the 20 grand a day that he
was asking for to represent Trump in the election
fraud matter. What a just torpedoing of a guy who,
again, like him or not, for better or worse, like
I'm not a big Giuliani guy, but I recognize he was
significantly well liked in 2002. Not
a great decision for Rudy Giuliani,
as far as I can see. Maybe in his mind, this is
working out great for him. I just don't see it.